the White House has been stressing that
it respects the sovereignty and
geostrategic priorities of African
nations and that it wouldn't use the
leader's Summit to lecture Nations about
doing business with U.S Rivals China and
Russia
but the US does want to expand its
footprint in Africa and Joe Biden used
his address at the summit to make the
argument that the U.S and its
corporations will be a great business
partner with African nations to ensure
Mutual success in the United States is
committed to supporting every aspect
every aspect of Africa's inclusive
growth and creating the best possible
environment for sustained commercial
engagement between Africa companies and
American companies the United States is
all in on Africa's future the second day
of the summit sold several hours of
panel discussions about the potential of
U.S African trade and investment but
everyone here is aware that China has
surpassed the US by a long way in
business and strategic Partnerships and
that the U.S is not thrilled with those
Investments what the Nations here have
been making clear is that they will not
be beholden to any power as they look to
the Future the president of the
Democratic Republic of Congo using a
photo opportunity to quietly criticize
the U.S after receiving condolences for
the flooding in the country that's
killed at least a hundred for example
you've just given us now sincere
condolences for the tragedy in
construction thank you for your
condolences but this is the very example
of what we have regretted for some time
the support from countries who pollute
and which unfortunately leads to
negative consequences in our countries
that cannot protect themselves from this
thank you very much Joe Biden isn't
having any bilateral meetings with the
African leaders here that's the
responsibility of Secretary of State
Anthony blinken instead the White House
said Biden would have informal little
moments with leaders at The Forum and at
a White House dinner it is fascinating
watching U.S officials trying hard not
to talk about what they feel are the
malign intentions of China and Russia
but they know that to do so is to
suggest that African nations are somehow
naive and unaware of the consequences of
their own strategic priorities
Al Jazeera Washington